which is which is like such a like flip
to whenever
well
when someone's going to come visit us in
japan because like you like i like when
a friend comes to visit in japan you're
just like what kind of experience do you
want because you could do anything you
can do anything yeah you want to see
nature do you want to see the city do
you want to see culture yeah did you
ever get sick ushering people around
japan because you were always the go-to
guy you had to take people around yeah
yeah yeah i was but uh after a while it
depends who i'm with like if i'm if i'm
with like a person who i'm not like you
know like super buddy buddy with them
obviously you know i want them to have a
good timing have a good impression but
if i'm just like you know it's just like
a [ __ ] mate from school or whatever
yeah then i used to do this thing where
i would take them to all these places
but then pretend i couldn't speak a word
of japanese
just to piss them off because i was like
i don't want to be the translator this
week so you know what let's see how you
like
so we would go to a restaurant and i
would be reading the menu and i'd be
like uh ego menu onegai shimasu just
[ __ ] pretend that i was foreign
because if i don't speak japanese
they'll never [ __ ] know yeah yeah so
they was just like come on just [ __ ]
help us help me translate this [ __ ]
thing and i was like nihongo and i i'm
sorry
yeah japan is just like local guide easy
mode yeah you can [ __ ] you go to like
a [ __ ] family man and they like blow
their minds yeah right like i just i
just take them like ikabuko and it's
done for the day yeah i know right you
can listen to this one one place yeah in
tokyo and that's their entire itinerary
done for the day yeah honestly time to a
ramen place like oh my god it's ramen
yeah it's like well that's the thing
right if you take them to like shibuya
you're easily like two days you could
spend there yeah if you take the cabra
that's a whole day again you're taking
me cabrera
is like several days yeah oh yeah
because you're gonna have one day and
they're like can we can we go back to
akihabara please i miss i missed when i
thought akihabara was like super fun and
amazing
as well well
just because all the figures you know
that the prices are always cheaper
elsewhere i've just found that the more
the the more times i've gone to arcabra
the more i realized that there was just
so much cool hidden [ __ ] there that
really if you're not there with someone
who knows the area really well it really
just does seem like here's the place to
buy anime figurines he's the buyer he's
the place to buy
i just don't have the time to explore it
anymore yeah that's true also
nearly all the restaurants i've been to
in akihabara are like severely
disappointed awesome i mean it's awful
awful i i said
i've had probably the worst meals in
japan consistently yeah
yeah same thing i don't know i think
because it's just on the front and then
you know everyone's like coming our
store well that's the thing it's like no
one really like no one really thinks to
themselves oh i want a really nice meal
let's go to oculus i hate the maids who
are like come on our straw please please
please yeah that is really annoying and
they're like igor dies your boo and i'm
like [ __ ] off
i don't know if it's daijoubu then get
this of course
i'm british i say it in my head i'm like
please leave me alone nice
human interaction get get out of here
get out get out of here
[Laughter]
i one time we walked past and there was
a maid that was like joey jump with that
no
she started like screaming like one of
the maids what the mate well who
recognized me yeah yeah i remember
this how do you remember this i don't i
i wait there actually what happened was
i was with you we were walking and i saw
the girl looking at you yeah and we kept
on walking and then i just heard her go
joey oh yes
and you i feel like you didn't pay any
attention you like whatever and just
kept walking then i was like
i do remember that actually because it's
like yeah i heard her say my name
but i thought like i didn't hear it as
my name until i walked past him and then
a process i was like i think she was
calling my name but then at that point
it was too late to like turn around and
be like
me
i don't want to be that guy right i'm
famous yeah he's like i'll just be the
cool guy just keep walking i just i i i
feel so unguarded whenever i get
recognized in japan yeah right
it really catches me off guard yeah it
really is scary because i i don't know
like one it's surprising to hear someone
speak english as well here and just just
on the streets and two like someone who
speaks english and also recognizes you
and it's especially i think since trash
taser started as well like i don't know
how i'm gonna handle going to my next
anime convention and there's just gonna
be like 70 million people calling me
grant and i'm just like i'm not going to
be able to tell the difference like if
they're just memeing or if they actually
think my name is grant i heard people at
the airport they're like welcome god
grant sorry welcome grant
yeah because i remember like people
already [ __ ] up my username they're like
yo you're the anime guy right i was like
yo the anime dude and i'm like i can't
wait to just be called like all these
[ __ ] nicknames i'm just like i don't
do you actually know who i am or you
just like taking the pierce because
sometimes i don't even know like when
some when when a person comes up to me
and goes
are you the anime guy i i don't know if
i'm supposed to go
i'm the anime man or if i'm supposed to
go
who's that who's that i'm not that good
who is that i don't know i don't know
who that guy is